what were your first
reactions when you saw what the arc of
the season was going to be
from for allison just for everybody
let's do both
i was really excited about allison's
journey this season i think you know we
get to see a side of allison we've never
seen before um you know she's kind of no
longer able to keep up this this facade
and and pretend and kind of keep people
out of how she's you know
really feeling and you know i think
everything that she went through in the
60s
there's without a doubt going to be
lingering trauma and that could be
lifelong and the effects of her time
there and what she saw and what she
experienced and what she survived
so i think i was really excited and i i
felt like we would be doing her such a
disservice if we didn't address that and
if we didn't
you know allow her time in the 60s to
affect
where she is now and and the
decision-making that she's making now um
and then i think for the season i think
i'm so proud of this season i think it
might be our best season yet i think
all of these characters are being thrust
into
to
kind of situations that we haven't
really seen them in before and and
they're kind of venturing into kind of
the unknown
in a really amazing way this isn't your
home
what are you talking about this is the
umbrella academy this is the sparrow
academy i also you know think
how we've incorporated elliot's and
victor's transition into into the season
is just
so remarkable and i'm so
proud of elliott and the journey um for
him and his vulnerability to to put that
on the screen and share that with the
world you know through victor as well i
think is just so spectacular
the the moments where
victor
becomes victor are some of the most
poignant and powerful but also
if there's a real subtlety to it that's
really really beautiful you can feel the
love come through the screen what was it
like when
you guys were shooting those people what
was it like on the day
you know it was it was really emotional
um you know ellie and i are really
really close in real life he's one of my
dearest and closest friends and i
you know i i have
knew that that this is this was on his
mind and this is this is
something that was really important to
him and and his transition and his
journey um with that and through that
and and so you know to be there for him
in real life it
has been such a blessing and i'm so
honored that he trusts me with that and
and and has brought me on that journey
with him how's umbrella academy going
and does it feel different now
i guess so yeah i mean because so much
feels different so many people have
commented on it in terms of
just how i feel in general and on set
but yeah it's going awesome
and to also then double down
in a way and be able to share that with
him on screen as victor and alison was
was really really emotional to kind of
in a way put a lot of the private
moments and private conversations that
him and i had you know behind closed
doors to kind of put that on camera
through these like aliases in a way was
was um
was really really special and and you
know i think
everyone on set and and steve blackman
and all our producers in the writer's
room you know i think we we really took
elliot's lead on on all of it and and
what he was comfortable with and and how
how much we wanted to he wanted to dive
into that and how much you know we as
the show would dive into that and and so
i think
i think the result is is really good
what the hell is a cougar blitz
essentially we're screwed
i think we're not beating anybody over
the head with it and i think at the end
of the day elliott
is proud of it and and i think that
that's that's all that matters to be
honest
yeah that was gonna be my next question
was if you if you had uh talked to him
after having watched how it turned out
and how those moments turned out and and
he is he's happy with him he's proud of
them
yeah i think i think we all are i think
i think you know we kind of were
you know heading off into the unknown
this has never happened before in
television so we're kind of he's he's
forging the frontier for this this
moment and and i think
i think beforehand when we were getting
the script and the those changes were
being made because you know the majority
of the first couple episodes had been
written
um before you know they decided to kind
of incorporate this transition for
victor into the scripts and so
uh he just seemed really happy in those
moments kind of getting the new scripts
and getting the new scenes and getting
the new dialogue and then i think i
think the end result seeing it on screen
i i cannot speak for him but i
i feel like he feels like it was done
perfectly and and in the right way and
then not you know
not over the top and not you know making
a whole episode about it and then kind
of diving you know diving too far into
it just kind of very matter of fact
which is kind of how it was with elliott
so let's fast forward to the end of the
season
uh allison is the one who presses the
button resets
the universe
where do you hope your character goes in
this if there's a fourth season i mean
you said yeah you know
she had this whole life in the 60s and
that impacted her changed her
what does that mean for her going
forward now that she's reset the
universe
you know i think making the decision
that she made i think in the moment in
the immediate it's this unbelievable
relief that not only did she get claire
back but she she also got ray back but i
do think
even though allison had quite the season
and was extremely reckless and and kind
of threw everybody else's feelings and
wants and needs
to the wayside so that she could very
single-mindedly get what she needed and
what she thought she deserved and what
she wanted
um
i think she's still alison i think she
is still her loyalty is is i think one
of her biggest character traits and and
i think
the effects of not knowing what this has
potentially done to her family i think
is going to eat her up inside and so i
think that would be really fun to play
with to see that so do you think she
wants to continue to be a part of that
family
yeah i mean i think
me i think yeah i think i think it's
undeniable i think as much as these
these people try to pretend like they
hate each other and they never they wish
that their lives would be so much easier
if they didn't all know each other i
think there's kind of there's this magic
in that they are the only ones that
truly ever understands
each each other though you know no one
will ever understand what it's like to
have grown up the way that they did and
have the abilities that they have and to
live the life the lives that they lead
um and so i think there will probably
come a time that she's gonna realize
that she does need them i think